No,
in actual fact we haven't discovered a
huge amount of obesity genes at the
moment,
but you know,
they're almost certainly is and we know
that there are genes involved in the
development of predisposition to
diabetes and so on and we know that
diabetes is going to becoming a massive
problem over the next sort of 20 to 30
years ago.
Estimates in the range of $400,
million people with diabetes by 2030
around the world.
And what we're,
what we would like to understand is how
does your genetic predisposition
interact with your environmental
predispositioned to,
you know,
culture,
um,
what,
what kind of foods that you eat,
you know,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And that's the piece that we want to try
and understand and sort of tease apart
and what for diabetics,
what does that mean in terms of your
likelihood of getting cardiovascular
disease and so on.
So I think those are the areas in which
is going to be a lot of work to try and
sort of understand the differences in
populations and the differences in rates
of obesity between different
populations.
How much of that is genetic,
how much of it is environment and what
can one do to get a to get around the
other?
So what,
what kind of lifestyle changes can you
make to get around your genetic
predisposition to developing obesity
and,
and also what kind of behavioral
components might make it difficult or
easy for you to do that?
You know,
because it's often very difficult for
people to change their lifestyle.
And that's where I,
that's where it's often a big challenge.
So we all know we're supposed to do in
order to keep healthy most of the time,
but it's difficult to do.